que DJ Drogba est un véritable
ambassadeur du football il est le
meilleur il est le meilleur il est le
meilleur dans ce qu'il fait l'amouron l'
on pe pas l'expliquer en
[Applaudissements]
fait il peutêtre mieux ici on est
andokoa le quartier
andokoa et c'est là qu'on a
vécu tout ça ça c'est au papa
de bonjour
madame je suis monsieur Go le frère de
Dr voil non non on passe ici pour voir o
il est né Dr tout ça cé la cour c'était
pas une cour
divisée c'est pas une cour
divisée et là tout ça c'était là-bas
jusquà av pas de m comme ça
ici les gens préparés
là préparé là la porte était là l'espace
existe oui je
vois donc
c'est je voulais qu'il jour pour que un
jour il puisse me remplacer il a fait
vraiment mieux que moi ça été pour moi
c'est une fierté quand tu amènes un
enfant qui réussit c'est une fierté
quand son père son père était jeune
c'est lui qui m'a amené à à Abidjan donc
c'est c'est une chaîne c'est les
Africains c'est une chaîne celui qui
part amène
quelqu'un venu pour montrer là où il a
vécu mais toute cette rue là depuis le
lycée tous les lycéens ont bloqué sa
voiture ici il PV pas sortir 4h ici il
peut pas
sortir incroyable c'est ça on a on
appelle le
[Musique]
succès et on met un poteau ici on
jou
mais là j'avais pas ces gravier là
c'était du c'était
Simp c'est la légende hein on ne peut
pas passer dans ce qutier sans parler
deuga c'est une fierté pour la Côte
d'Ivoire et c'est surtout pour notre
quartier c'est une fierté franchement
tout le monde quand tu demandes un petit
je veux être droga je veux être droga
j'aimerais être un grand fotbolur comme
drba on était très fier de lui c'est la
chance d'avoir un professionnel dans
notre re
quartier B
ok sa manière de jouer ça détermination
et sa manière de se battre pour son pays
ça donne l'envie de le ressembler ça
donne l'envie re comme lui c'est un
exemple pour moi parce qu'on peut venir
de nulle part et devenir un héos demain
c'est quelqu'un qui est courageux voilà
qui donne envie qui motive les jeunes de
ce pays le message qu'il donne souvent
c'est croire en nous voilà ne jamais
baisser les
bras je pense que avait un projet voilà
porteur pour les C d' formation voilà je
pense que voilà que c'était ce n que
parti remise et il
s'investira davantage pour le
développement du football des jeunes
dans notre pays quoi qu'on dise il reste
une référence voilà pour le football de
haut niveau en Côte d'Ivoire voilà donc
je pense que il reste et il restera
longtemps grav dans les mémoire des
jeunes
[Musique]
footballeurs
éorme